hey guys i'm ryan right hey guys i'm sad
man dude so today we're gonna check out
a video from alltime10s
ten awful crimes committed by famous
celebrities here we go
I'm interested to see who's on this list
let's see about some violence out there
Matthew Broderick's what did he do
19 Center Butterfield
- woman in a car crash when he drove
into the wrong lane oh my god his victim
died instantly for the crime Roderich of
Planet 175 bucks heads cartel the
Jamaican dancehall star was sentenced to
life in prison for the murder of an
associate Wow
cartel boasted that his victim had been
chopped or smallest body will never be
found
Shawn panty [ __ ] up Madonna he was
charged with domestic assault for
hitting den wife McDonough in the head
with a baseball bat on another occasion
he broke into her house tighter to a
chair for nine hours gagged and
assaulted her free command he's a great
actor so I forgive him for all it says
Mark Wahlberg I remember this one Peter
play some Asian dude 8:16 Wahlberg was
in charged with attempted murder for his
humble attack on two Vietnamese been
walking Vietnamese [ __ ] Vietnamese
time before smashing one's head with a
stick and punching this such a victim of
the face
the punch beating these guys mike tyson
- my h13 you've been arrested 38 times
crimes including burglary a thousand
narcotic use in 1992 we spent three
years in prison for raping and a little
beauty queen that's not funny oh that's
horrible did not do Mike Tyson Charlie
Sheen he was arrested for beating his
girlfriend knocking her out and leaving
her needing seven stitches he was
holding a knife to his wife Brooke
Mueller struggling and killer oh my god
he's insane all the time but he's such a
great comedic actor - jay-z he pleaded
guilty to stabbing record producer Lance
Rivero Wow
shot his brother in the shoulder for
stealing its ring - well I would talk
[ __ ] got in there - no
Oh Simpson
although acquitted and criminal trial
civil trial found in guilty for the
double murder of his ex-wife and her
friend 2007 he was sentenced of 33 years
in prison and armed robbery and
kidnapping charges in an attempt to
retrieve a sports memorabilia [ __ ] OJ
man
Oscar Pistorius may the Lord just bless
you all your sins into 2012 Paralympic
and Paralympic paralimbic God yo man
you're claiming this [ __ ] Bernie
shooter and was found guilty of culpable
homicide oh my god jimmy savile
I don't know that is
various children's TV presenter Jimmy
Savile easily accessible sexually abused
up to 400 adults and children sex acts
on corpses and made jewelry with the
dead victim of glass eyes out some tears
that was 10 awful crimes committed by
surgeries awful stop my shocking stuff
what and if you want to see more
celebrity content they might also enjoy
10 actors who started out on porn linked
to lastly the John as an intern in
Scripture as always guys thanks for
watching I don't get to subscribe see
you next time
ill hell last woman had me all kinds of
messed up oh my god um that's kind of
like the guy that uh voiced Elmo or
something was committed convicted of
like child like it's so creepy to me to
like yeah you're gonna use facts no
haven't really the guy who's in the
Barney suit two people were in
children's filming well it's the
smartest playground for pedophilia
honestly I'm not saying do it I'm not
saying it's good I'm just saying it's if
one two were to be a pedophile it's the
it's the best playground for it that guy
just looked messed up I don't know who
would put him on a television sorry but
uh him on television the heat early um
just look crazy
okay there's several that surprising
Matthew Broderick Oh shocking kill two
women and he got charged $175 and he was
off the hook
I mean think about what happened with
Bruce Jenner he also killed someone and
I don't even think he got charged
anything I mean we don't know who these
two women were there Matthew Broderick
those people it certainly helps not a
hundred and seven dollars well that's
like you know the [ __ ] 175 bucks t6
wig food food going to one grocery store
like that's like going to the strip club
that's been way too much money
I get pressured easily okay I get
pressured very easily
20s every time
it's you're gonna be on this little soon
yeah I'm gonna kill a stripper matthew
broderick got away with straight-up
murder no you probably is still dealing
with it look imagine if you accidentally
killed someone in a car wreck like I
doubt he was like oh I'm gonna hit these
people to kill them like no how do you
know Matthew Broderick could be a
[ __ ] psychopath he's married to Sarah
Jessica Parker who looks like a horse
chair no I actually think she's pretty
I'm just joking I've heard someone else
say that I thought it was hilarious
pretty much all the Internet's Sean Penn
I did cover this before in another video
but that still shocks me Mel Gibson put
out a tape I mean even put out a ticket
yeah well people listen to this audience
know he's audio got released where he
admitted to hitting his ex-girlfriend
yeah and then everyone was like everyone
was like okay with the Jewish with the
Jewish racist insults and now with this
domestic violence against his wife as
its girlfriend at the time his career
was ruined right Sean Penn [ __ ] beat
hit her with a baseball bat in the head
to broken tie her down like it's insane
and yet he has so much respect as an
actor so yeah that really sickens me
honestly yeah I know it sickens me just
because Mel Gibson cannot be forgiven
when Sean Penn has been forgiven yeah
then again II didn't do it summoned oh
no I mean I always have like I can look
at actors and sometimes I'm like I don't
like them and I just don't like them and
there's just a reason and then usually I
find out that they're kind of messed up
I never liked Sean Penn's you never did
I don't like to Oscars know he always
like kind of like made me feel weird
when I was watching him like I just
there was something about him I just
didn't like do you feel like he was like
in you know cuz that would be weird you
know don't know sometimes you just watch
someone you're like I just don't like
them recently about the middle did you
hear my Sean Penn is trip I'll tend to
tune you out will menace jokes about
I'll say it enough times where you might
laugh Sean Penn is Sean Dennis
it's good enough for me hmm
I forgot about all that Charlie Sheen
[ __ ] with like [ __ ] like holding a
knife up against one of the wife beating
a girlfriend like that that is insane
Charlie Sheen more like Charlie mean oh
just dissed you Charlie Sheen just
pissed you know winning I did not know
that about jay-z and that kind of really
why is he married to Beyonce well it was
in 1999 and okay he stabbed a record
producer the record producer don't know
anything about this record producer but
if Jeezy stabbed him probably had did he
die or no I think he just stabbed him
okay that's don't messed up it's messed
up but you know like maybe they didn't
agree on a track and jay-z's musics
really good so if someone doesn't agree
with the track that Jeezy really likes
jay-z's gonna stab you simple fact
simple facts he'd better not touch
Beyonce or I'll come after him and did
he touch the may you don't touch the day
unless you're smacking that ass oh yeah
when he was 12 he shot his brother in
the shoulder for stealing his ring
that's another thing you know like um
things I thought about it I wouldn't
actually do it and you actually did it
well I can understand that when you're
12 you're angry you're confused you
don't get along with your brother you
know like maybe it was his parents fault
for I don't know me he's an easy for em
group Teaneck going at 12
maybe I mean my parents gave me a gun
when I was 12 I shot my brother for
similar reasons you don't take one of my
french fries and then dip it in my
ketchup and double dip it too you had
the audacity to double dip his french
fry shot him in the balls that's right
my brother has no testicles Jabby koi
Tran we'll check it out just promoted
you bro well anyway guys thanks for
tuning in to the channel where we
discuss movie related news and
celebrities apparently if you're new to
it you can subscribe to the real rejects
you can check out salamander Sally's
channel on the sally channel with the
Sally and you can follow us on Facebook
Instagram Twitter vine periscope because
if we get enough followers we can get
even more product listen meaning money
growing from
he's in my backyard Andre nip urease
turkey gay Ryan hey hey I think no he
meant gay gay Ryan I actually don't know
how to get a shout-out but I follow the
link mmm the description so I love your
videos and it'll be awesome if you can
say hi to Peru and I love salamander
Sally I did not know this was coming Wow
let's see what they look like I love you
too Andre de Parys du chí oh oh I think
that's the TV what you mean
Wow Nick do you want to see the face of
the man who Sally wants to have a
threesome with all right cool so one in
the middle
No someone in the middle just like [ __ ]
don't get it get upset or you won't get
upset well doing your girlfriend you
pretended it's all your fault Andre you
got involved